YACINE REZGUI: Android
Q Beta is now available,
which brings us one step
closer to the final release.
We want to make sure your
applications work properly
by the time Android Q updates
are released to the public.
In this video, we will
discuss the Android Q Beta
program, its timeline,
available developer resources,
and explain the two
options you have
for testing it, installing
it on your device,
or using an emulator image.
To give you another view
on the release process,
the first three beta milestones
provide an early test
and development environment to
help you identify compatibility
issues in your current apps.
At beta 4, you will have
access to the final APIs
and SDK to develop with as
well as updated beta system
images to test system
behaviors and features.
Also starting beta
4, you will be
able to publish apps to
device running Android
Q at the official API level.
At beta 5 and 6, you will
have release candidate builds,
which includes the final APIs
and near-final system images.
As you test and
develop, we strongly
recommend keeping your
development environment up
to date as beta
updates are released.
The Android Q
preview SDK includes
changes that are not
compatible with some older
versions of entry studio.
For the best development
experience with the Android Q
preview SDK, we recommend
that you install the latest
version of Android Studio.
After you open Android
Studio, download and install
the Android Q preview SDK
using the SDK manager.
You will also need to update
your platform build tools
to version 28 or higher.
Finally, you can
create virtual device
by downloading the Q image
and use it as the deployment
target for your application.
If you have a Pixel
device, you can install
Android Q beta on your phone.
To download the beta, go to
g.co/androidbeta and obtain
to the beta program.
After restarting
your device, you
can navigate through the system
update screen on your phone
and tap the Update button
to download and install
Q. If you want to revert
your phone to Android Pie
after your test, you
can simply opt out
of the beta program
from the same address
and update your device from the
system update screen as before.
Be aware that this process will
remove all locally saved data
on your device.
With above
preparations complete,
you can build your
app and then conduct
basic compatibility testing on
behavior and privacy changes.
Finally, update the target
SDK in your Gradle file
for further testing and
adoption of new features.
For more information on new
features and changes in Q,
check out the links in the
description of the video.
Enjoy Android Q. Leave us
feedback on your experience
using the beta.
We've provided several
ways to capture comments,
including a bug tracker.
[MUSIC PLAYING]